ciao ciao
benvenuti su rytas oggi a grandissima
richiesta tornano gli indovinelli questa
volta noi avremo due pulsanti chi preme
in premier primo potrà dare la risposta
sta nella risposta sbagliata 0 punti e
della risposta giusta
un punto anche voi potrete giochetti
meno ospitale a parte che fa casino come
sempre anche voi dovrete giocare tema
noi noi bloccheremo prima che arrivi la
risposta
e voi dovreste scrivere la vostra
risposta nei commenti vediamo che riesce
a fare più punti per fare più punti di
noi allora mettetevi comodi patatine
snack tè caldo quello che volete e
iniziamo subito indovinello numero uno
allora un terrorista ha preso il
controllo della è fatto richiede dei
soldi e due paracaduti una volta che ha
ricevuto dei due paracaduti salta fuori
dall'aereo to stop sul deserto un
deserto ma usa solo un paracadute
eccoli infatti cosa gustare solo di quel
detto ma cosa vi serviva il secondo
presente allora io do la mia risposta
non penso che sia giusto perché un po
stupida secondo mese fa un po recante di
serviva per mettere studi dentro è
quella richiuso oppure per far scendere
i soldi col paracadute altrimenti il
peso sarebbe stato troppo e se sarebbe
sfracellato a terra anche se
nell'immagine e sodi ma l'attaccante
scrivete voi nei commenti la vostra
risposta dovrebbe essere valido maioli
io dico che invece il secondo paracadute
serviva per depistare quindi quando
tutti quando lo sapevano prendi e ha
fatto meglio del secondo per ripetuto è
sempre solo come depistaggio per
depistare ovviamente una rata è poi
caduto vanno trovate la politica che va
a prenderlo
la nostra terra allora scrivete voi la
vostra risposta nei commenti
ora potete anche mettere in pausa il
video su una volta tanto imposti vela e
vediamo la risposta hanno assistendo
tubicino di omero allora la risposta è
appreso il secondo paracadute per far
pensare alla polizia che stava saltando
dall'aereo con un ostaggio
così la pulizia non avrebbe danneggiato
il suo paracadute tornei dello stage per
dare i dentisti ha purtroppo con me e
non abbiamo messo in palio messo in cibo
però è che non mi pare questo no allora
vitale a un punto io zero indovinello
numero 22 persone hanno ucciso un uomo
chi è stato vediamo se c'è qualche
indizio questo
domenica pomeriggio mister devis è stato
trovato morto sotto la neve fuori dalla
sua casa c'è una mamma che è diventato
nero sotto la neve la polizia ha
interrogato tutti i sospettati
sospettati il giardiniere risponde stavo
togliendo la neve dal cespugli la
sorella invece dice io stavo seduta
il fuoco sia il camion o il fuoco dice
in stiamo preparando la colazione la
colazione di pomeriggio invece la
governante a vari fasi del letto la
moglie stava leggendo e aspettando la
sua colazione ma nel pomeriggio la
polizia ha arrestato due persone
chi è stato da è la governante del fuoco
perché perché se la moglie stava
aspettando la colazione il poco vuol
dire che non lo stava preparando la
moglie stava aspettando la colazione
quindi il fuoco non avevo ancora
preparato lavorazione che nikon complice
la governante che stava rifacendo il
letto si mangia mazzarella sonno e poi
dopo l'hanno buttato fuori con due vedo
vernante tempo la moglie aspettava
tranquilla quando hanno visto che il
giardiniere si era allontanato con la
mela secondo me immersi sono stazza
governo anche giardiniere perché la
governante mentre mi fossi aver letto
appunto poteva ucciderlo mentre dormiva
e poi giardiniere l'ha nascosto nella
neve che vediamo la vostra risposta nei
commenti del sediamo chi ha vinto questa
cosa
[Applauso]
nazionale zuccherina parte dall'inizio
chi perché è semplice perché non
potevano lasciare di pomeriggio e la
risposta è sono state la moglie il congo
perché chi è che cucina lavorazione di
cui che cosa stava passando la colazione
e la moglie sto aspettando
va beh noi non abbiamo fatto nessun
punto per loro niente sono in vantaggio
ma le avete indovinato il livello 2 o 3
dai la moglie del signor smith e come
sarà fatta il detective è venuto ad
investigare il caso volta che l'ho vista
stava stava facendo colazione a tutti ma
l'azione bargain bluetooth rizzini nel
dover spiegare una decorazione interna e
bombe con i banchetti a fianco
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sono tornato a casa alle cinque di
pomeriggio
ma la colazione era ancora sul tavolo
delle era sparita perché il detective è
stato il signor smith se con me che
quale risposte stupidissime tipo lui
alice ha detto che l'ha vista l'ultima
volta che la vis stava facendo colazione
foreste inter è anche stava mangiando e
prendete che cosa fare una circolazione
ancora anni esattamente secondo me la
risposta così stupida spero di no però
anch'io pensa lo stesso risiedono un
gioco di parole note la pista fare
colazione con the tornato alla colazione
era ancora lì i media 31 st
l'indovinello di avere 3m in commenti e
mediana era sparita voglio tecnico
perché era recato a profano voi cioè a
lorella esposte ad realta non si
avvicinano un po però non è proprio
quello che abbiamo detto noi non so se
avete notato nell'immagine mentre noi
guardavamo c'era il fumo che usciva dai
pancakes l'anno calcio però è però
pensato vabbè sarà l'animazione che
hanno messo in realtà la risposta è che
la colazione era ancora calda quindi il
signor smith ha preparato il tutto
quindi la colazione prima di chiamare la
polizia e quindi la polizia e gli altri
ceo l'adorazione montata stamattina non
è
avete indovinato voi dove il numero 4
una donna non riesce ad addormentarsi
nella sua stanza di hotel dopo un paio
di ore fa una telefonata o una
telefonata alessando armi e variante
logorando giustamente non dice niente e
chiude la telefonata cioè non scriviamo
e poi c'è il tormento
a chi è chiamato a chi ha chiamato in
questo difficile per addormentarsi dai
ha chiamato dal sentire sui figli erano
tornati a casa perché non poteva dormire
perchè ero preoccupato per i figli è una
buona risposta proprio perché sia
qualcosa di più interessante di questo
il xv che secondo me ha chiamato aspetta
lei non ha detto niente non ha detto
niente nella chiamata quindi come fa
sapere se i film sono a casa e chiamato
qualcuno che la ipnotizzata al telefono
ed ha fatto addormentare
e voi la risposta nei commenti vediamo
[Musica]
allora s'è scritto che ha chiamato la
stampa accanto per svegliare il nuovo
talento geniale però non avevano detto
che non si vede perché non riuscivo a
dormire per te la dentina rumore è vabbè
non ho mai dirlo noi ma sappi che è
stato mi è piaciuta basta risposta
perché era veramente intelligente
sì avete indovinato la difficile con
quindi mai 8.0 punti allora indovinello
chi è che sta mantenendo le coste di un
fiume rapido e profondo un criminale è
passato in mezzo a noi ed è saltato nel
fiume mattino vediamo qua dietro penso
in maniera che vediamo nella foto e
mezzo perché il detective sapeva che
stavamo già mettendo in ricapitoliamo un
criminale
gli e passato davanti a loro e
attraversato il fiume e lo vediamo un po
dietro è arrivato il detective e lui
hanno detto western detective ma gillet
si sa che è una bugia perché sospetto è
qui tra loro è uno di loro secondo me
questo qui con le mutande lo slogan non
prendere in giro la gente lo guarda
allora secondo me lui o la aiutano con
una barchetta qualche modo hanno aiutato
perché il fiume rapido e profondo piani
non poteva semplicemente correre lì
attraverso il fiume pensa che il fiume a
profondo che non ho potuto arrivare dal
nostro esatto
va beh più o meno abbiamo dato la stessa
cosa quindi un punto a testa ore 21 se
avete indovinato lo stesso un punto
prossimo indovinello numero 55 numero 5
allora un detective è scomparso lo vedrò
ha lasciato un codice per la polizia che
l'inizio chi è il criminale di qualche
altro indizio il sono impossibile ok
allora di scoprire chi è il criminale
tra john bill ea da una tramite questo
codice
oddio ma molto difficile proviamo con
lettere dell'alfabeto
ci sono troppi numeri perché sono per di
tanti numeri ma ragazzi mi arrendo e
veramente troppo difficile questo non so
che anche che tipo di risposta dai
buttiamo si dice a casa
io dico che è stato john perché ha la
faccia molto arrabbiata io dico che è
stato adam intascano mai in buffy e amo
cosa c'è scritto qualcosa se la mettiamo
al contrario di steve hill
be nice boh non so cosa vuol dire
e poi se un giorno la durata può vedere
anche questa foto
allora indovinello il numero 6 una
mattina di autunno il detective colombo
corre subito nel parco giochi per
giocare nelle fila granata dove dove
molti bambini sono stati rapiti
fate le domande quattro persone che sono
lì nella zona è interrogato
no
[Applauso]
il primo è tonno che bisogna stava
pescando vicino al fiume
[Musica]
la somma dei link che dice io stavo al
salone di bellezza la ladies stanno
facendo delle foto di vegetazione di
cementazione quinto anno del verde
contorno maryann che aveva marianna dai
a in tale un po d'italia mentre stavo
facendo una passeggiata al parco quindi
è l'unica che stava al parco per un
parco giochi al parco
[Musica]
puoi identificare chi è almeno un
traditore
almeno uno quindi ce ne sono più di uno
io dico 2 che non miri clean
mi sembra che si chiama lin la numero 2
che dice che lei era la stessa zona di
bellezza ma se il salone di bellezza che
ci fa dopo al parco e poi la numero 4
marianna che dice io non vedo faceva una
passeggiata al parco
non lo so questo questo mini e mi ispiro
e allora allora scalzo fare con il paese
in mano
non sono sicura che sia stata in grado
di andare al parco giochi mentre pescava
io dico la numero 303 perché non mi
convince è la numero 4 perché lavoro
perché stava al parco vicino al parco
giochi
la numero 3 che ha stamani facevano foto
e nel verde qui vicino a sabato prossimo
vediamo scrivete la vostra risposta dei
commenti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si sarà illuminata laura è una dei
rapitori
[Musica]
[Applauso]
perché lei sta facendo una foto del mae
autunno quindi il parto non può essere
così verde strumento che è l'altro beh
noi abbiamo già da solo nostro risposta
con di commentare dice allora è in
ognuno numero 7 ultime due euro v
concentriamo significa nostrani siamo 10
no allora io ho fatto un punto e privato
indovinata quindi siamo due azzurre alla
capitale altre oppure essere un cielo
sempre stato un secolo ma i miei chiama
amore per il milan è già dimenticato
tutto si fa comunque dove nel numero 7
questi quando vinello concentriamoci al
dm anni facciamo anna e fitto e come
l'italiano che però alle pietro vogliono
controllare quale l'ascensore
superveloce wood entrano
contemporaneamente negli ascensori e e
premono il dottore del piano terra
[Musica]
ognuno muore che consiglia di provvista
che adunate di guardare chi è che
arriverà primo
[Applauso]
ma tu ti sei distratto per un momento
ovviamente dalle tasse ma ryan
[Musica]
quando ti sei girato
entrambi erano già arrivati quindi non
sei arrivato prima
chi è arrivato prima
allora quindi scrivete pure nei commenti
la vostra risposta prima che la diciamo
noi allora è in realtà nell'animazione
si è visto che si è aperto prima la sua
porta ma non si vedeva bene però se la
porta di pietro è già chiusa vuol dire
che è arrivato prima lui invece la sua è
ancora aperta quindi io dico pietro
anch'io è stranissimo vediamo pietro
perché la porta dietro di lui era già
chiusa quindi entrambi facciamo un punto
che sono stato prima io invece vi
diciamo che siamo 3 a 3 ea mio avviso in
parità di maggiori risorse tenuto aperto
l'elettore prima azionato il pulsante
per primo che è giusto che hai vinto tu
quindi bari sapere se avete fatto tre
punti anche voi il bello disappunto
possono avere indovinate tutte un po
impossibile visto che ormai le risposte
erano stranissime ombre la lista per
senso piaciuti questi domini assieme
alle signore che hanno fatto a farli
quindi speciale altri lasciato in
braille che se volete vederne altri e
ora vi lascio cuba 4 katelinas
conficcare altri giochi divertenti e
reazioni challenge slime cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao